you know some of us
classes at 1:30 this way I would like to
to start
privilege and honor to introduce a good
friend of mine a fantastic lady with the
brilliant history in diplomacy
ambassador current peers
what is interesting that I don't know if
it is a coincidentally or not but yeah
we have meetings every 10 years in night
1997 I was appointed as deputy
ambassador to London and at a time
Vassar Pierce was the chair of the
Russia Belarus and Ukrainian desk and
then in ten years
I arrived to United Nations to service
ambassador there and ambassador Pierce
was at that time deputy ambassador of
United Kingdom and now again so this is
really pretty sure in order to introduce
ambassador
she has just arrived just fresh only a
few months in in March but what a
tremendous work she did well I took some
pictures only well just to from your
Twitter well look our Bishop of
Canterbury
so ambassador Pierce is promoting the
interfaith dialogue
well declaration on the peacekeeping
initiative which was adopted this year
United Kingdom was one of the in the
first rows promoting the changes and
approaches to the peacekeeping well the
the Syrian conflict United Kingdom and
the mission is the leader in fighting
the way out of this crisis well chemical
weapons and recently welded the the
differences inside the Security Council
between several permanent members
including Russia so that's why I have
privilege to introduce our dear guests
today and one once again on picture
Columbia
Columbia were United Kingdom standing
behind the peace building process there
and successful process and this is the
final act when ambassador Pierce has a
meeting with the leaders of of Columbia
and the ambassador of Columbia to the
United Nations and again it's my
privilege to introduce you know he well
professor David Cameron director of
European studies program at the Yale
University and he will moderate today's
meeting with that ambassador I invite
you to take to take the floor and thank
you for being with us today
well thank you very much EURion Thank
You professor Cameron and thank you to
the Jackson Institute for inviting me
today it's a great honor to be here I'm
afraid it's my first visit to Yale
I know Harvard quite well so I apologize
in advance but for that but I'm hoping
to get to know Yale a little bit today
and I've just spent some time at the
British art gallery downtown
which of course was given by Paul Mellon
and there were some really wonderful
pieces there so if anyone hasn't been to
that gallery I think it's well worth a
visit professor Cameron was telling me
that he's a lifer from Yale which is
obviously very distinguished I went to a
different Cambridge myself I went to
Cambridge in in the South of England but
it is delightful to be here and I've
just met some world fellows from Britain
who were studying here at Yale and
clearly it was very careless of me not
to have managed as an America file to
have included on my CV a stint here
doing the world Fellows program we
usually send someone from the British
government each year and we haven't got
anyone this year but that's something I
should be trying to rectify and I'll
show you use it as an incentive to
encourage heist
and as a performance in the UK mission
in New York say thank you again for
inviting me I've been asked to talk
about Europe after brexit but also about
the UN and multilateralism which is very
timely given the UN General Assembly
that we've just had and I thought if I
talked for about 20-25 minutes and then
left the balance of time for you to ask
questions that might work quite well but
if you want to interrupt me please feel
free to do so I don't mind that at all
most days I do a press briefing and
they're not polite so I suggest that you
operate on the same principle as I said
this UN General Assembly was a very
timely moment for what we call the
rules-based international order but one
might also think about it as a system of
multilateralism and I think it's fair to
say that there is a great deal of
unpredictability in the world at the
moment and there is a great deal of
uncertainty about how in the 21st
century a hundred years after the end of
the first world war which set or began
to set many of the frameworks and the
country boundaries that we cope with
today what is happening to the global
order and it is under challenge from a
lot of different places and I'll come on
to those in a minute
I think I would say that reports of the
death of multilateralism or the world
rules-based international order and much
exaggerated but I think there is no
doubt that international power dynamics
a complicating the execution of that
rules-based international order and
certainly are making the foundations for
the UN which ought to sit at the top of
the system and it has kept us all safe
that system since 1945 kept us safe and
prosperous
I think it's fair to say that UN now
sits on a shaky foundation than it used
to and then you have challenges such as
the Russian invasion and annexation of
Crimea and some people would add Europe
and the United Kingdom leaving the EU
into the list of challenges but I'll
come on to that later if I may I think
since its foundation in 1945 the UN has
always suffered from a gap between the
noble purpose and the high levels of
ambition of its founders and the reality
so the UN has always struggled in a way
to put that core purpose into practice
that's not to say it hasn't done some
truly amazing things it gave us the
concept of peace gatekeeping it feeds
something like 480 million people it
vaccinates
90 million people at its best
the UN's the protector and Savior even
of millions of ordinary citizens around
the world but it isn't always fit for
purpose and in many ways this challenge
that's coming to set the rules of the
competition it's a competition to set
the rules of international affairs
primarily between the west and the likes
of Russia and China but there are other
elements in that that make this a
particularly complicated question and I
don't know how many people here grew up
with an innate love of appreciation for
the United Nations and everything it was
meant to represent I grew up in six
beers with a whole series of TV programs
like Man From UNCLE
and Thunderbirds and my all-time
favorite the champions which to indicate
a break with the Cold War was set in
Geneva in neutral country and amazingly
enough represented the armed wing of the
United Nations which is a very strange
concept but my point is that in the 60s
it would have been unthinkable to think
that more un more supranational
institutions were not the way to go and
this was reflected in popular culture
and we've come on quite a journey since
that point I think there are as we saw
at the UN General Assembly this
September people are starting to realize
that the real space system is under
challenge and they are starting to rally
to its defence and what you saw when all
the leaders spoke in the General
Assembly was a huge amount of sentiment
defending the UN defending international
law and defending multilateralism for
its own sake now that's a very different
thing from putting that into practice
and individual leaders taking individual
choices which will reinforce those three
things but it was striking that very few
leaders joined President Trump in his
distinction between patriotism and
globalism
most leaders wanted there to be both
together and that would certainly be the
view of the British government they're
not antithetical those two concepts they
exist side-by-side certainly my mission
is there not only to promote global
goods and values but also to defend
promote in advance
British interests and we see no no
contradiction there and it was
interesting that countries like the
Chinese the Indians some of the smaller
countries while calling for the UN to
reform did rally to the notion that the
multilateral system
shirring japanese defending at the
moment and I think one consequence of
that will be how do we prepare for the
UN's 75th anniversary in 2020 there may
be some very fundamental things coming
ought to be coming about how we reform
the UN and how we make it modernize so
that it isn't seen as a 70 year old
institution that's still trying to deal
with the end of the Cold War that it
really does become a very modern
enterprise and that of course will
involve modernizing its structures
modernizing the Charter and looking at
Security Council reform which is quite a
difficult issue for all sorts of
political as well as technical reasons
and we can come back that to that one of
the most interesting speeches at the UN
General Assembly that's just passed was
that of the Russian Foreign Minister now
he has a riff that he likes to play out
that it's the end of the West's modern
times at the end of the West there the
end of Western European values there the
end of the system that was set up after
the first world war after the Second
World War but I think in the context
particularly of this year being the 70th
anniversary of the Universal Declaration
of Human Rights that is a narrative we
need to push back on and I'll come on to
that in a minute and I think there are
some inherent characteristics of the
multilateral system today that are
leading it to be particularly vulnerable
in addition to the international power
dynamics I mentioned at the beginning
and I think there are broadly five of
these areas I think the first is
obviously the International power
dynamic it's a more aggressive Russia
and we saw that with Crimea we saw that
with what it's doing in the Donbass but
not only there we have seen it on the
streets of Salisbury in the United
Kingdom we have seen it in the tolerance
if not in Kerry
for Syria to use chemical weapons in
eastern guter and doom are chemical
weapons are prohibited under
international law they are a form of
weapons of mass destruction we would
argue that the Russians as a permanent
member of the Security Council should be
joining us in trying to uphold and
reinforce these prohibitions as opposed
to vetoing moves in the Security Council
to try and do just that so you have a
very uncertain and aggressive Russia you
have a more assertive China China
pursues her aims in a different way at
the UN from from Russia she is both
possible to work with China even as we
may contest and oppose some of the
things she does on human rights some of
the things she does in the South China
Seas nevertheless in certain areas
particularly health it is possible to
work at the UN and in the multilateral
context with China but we need to be
very careful that the belton Road
initiative does not become a vehicle for
Chinese asset stripping of the countries
it invests in from our perspective that
belt and Road initiative is welcomed if
it genuinely enables the economic
development prosperity and political
representation of the countries where
China is investing and I think there is
a question mark over that last point and
then of course you have the position of
the United States
I personally having been the trade
ambassador in Geneva think president
Trump has a good point about the way
China is cheating and not playing by the
rules of the International Trading
system but I think above all those of us
on the other side of the Atlantic we
want to see a stronger America since
1945 world affairs has never known an
America that isn't engaged in detail
with a whole
of international affairs and certainly
at the UN countries define themselves by
what America thinks either to support
America or to oppose it but if there's
no American voice then a lot of things
go by default and at the moment neither
Europe nor China are ready or mature
enough for want of a better word to step
into America's shoes and America has
been overall such a force for good in
the world at its best what Roosevelt
called the righteous application of
force that we we do believe America
first also equals America engaged
however much we support America in
defending her individual interests so I
think that is a very important thing
theme of International Affairs those of
you who enjoy reading dr. Kissinger's
books will be aware of his argument that
the New World Order will involve the US
and China
somehow finding a modus vivendi and I
think that that has to be right but at
the same time I think it would be a very
detrimental step if that modus vivendi
took us back into the old Cold War style
spheres of influence and I think that's
something to avoid
I think the second theme I'd
particularly highlight that challenges
the system at the moment is the role of
the emerging powers when the UN was
founded there were 55 member states 11
of them so one-fifth sat in the Security
Council now you have another 193 member
states and you have 15 members of the
Security Council five permanent members
and even if we enlarge the Security
Council we are clearly not going to take
it up to being a fifth of the membership
so there is a representation deficit
that you see echoed in some of the other
big international institutions and
how that representational deficit is
going to have to be remedied either at
the 75th or 80th anniversary or in some
other way if we do not manage to remedy
it then I think we will find that large
powerful countries growing countries
like India will simply take their
international business elsewhere and it
will become much more inter-governmental
rather than supranational they will use
other fora
outside the multilateral system what you
might think of as plurilateral already
organizations like the web the Shanghai
Cooperation Organization are trying to
take on some of the roles that more
naturally would go to the United Nations
and its agencies and then I think
another feature of that is that you have
a lot more activity in international
affairs one only has to look at the
Middle East and compare it to ten years
ago to see how many more countries are
active on the world stage for good or
for ill there isn't an existentialist
rivalry between Saudi Arabia and Iran
that is driving some of the conflict the
British government is on record at
setting out its opposition to a lot of
what Iran is doing in the region and of
course the Iranian position is not new
but I can remember immediately after
9/11 when it was possible to work with
Iran so there is something about finding
a way to work with these nude I would
say new powers because some of the
countries have a very long and
distinguished record but I will say
newly assertive powers newly
economically developed powers and that
is making a big difference and this is
one of the Russian foreign ministers
contentions and I think a feature of
that also is that countries are simply
less impressed with the West than they
used to be for a whole range of
reasons but it also plays in to how they
view human rights I think ten five years
ago it would have been XE ematic to most
countries on the Human Rights Council
that there was a direction of travel on
social issues on human rights issues on
LGBT issues for example and that they
may go along that trajectory more slowly
than others but there was never a doubt
that it was the right direct direction
to follow and I am not so sure that one
could say that today even in the 70th
anniversary year of the Universal
Declaration and so somehow we have to
get back to that Universal Declaration
which was ahead of its time when drafted
in 1948 and puts a huge emphasis on
equality before the law which countries
ought to be able to rally to and then my
third theme would be if there are new
countries there are also new issues
disruptive technology cyber artificial
intelligence an open Internet these are
all areas where the international
community in the multilateral system has
I went say flailed around a bit but
there aren't the same mechanisms for
these interesting hybrid areas that
there are for some of the more classic
types of hard security and we are going
to have to get to grips with that
because if we don't then countries that
our authoritarian will start to use the
international system in order to put in
place frameworks and controls that will
work again a multi sectoral model going
across government across civil society
across the private sector academia in
the media in favor of one almost wholly
beholden to government and on top of
that I would say counterterrorism there
aren't any really good international
mechanisms even through the UN on
counterterrorism peacekeeping is all
about Millett
trees on the ground trying to keep a
piece that is seen as static
counterterrorism requires much more law
enforcement it requires getting the
balance with human rights right it
requires a lot of police work and at the
international level that is exactly
where the security gap is and then
lastly I'd add into the mix the fact
that as I said earlier the system we
have is based on 1945 it's very state to
state but a lot of what happens in the
world these days for good for bad comes
from non-state actors it comes from
multinational corporations
it comes from terrorists it comes from
insurgents and yet the legal frameworks
are very much based on state to state
obligations so there is something in
that about a mismatch between what's
actually happening in the world and the
international cooperation frameworks on
a legal basis that we have to deal with
that so for all those reasons I think
the multilateral system is under
challenge but I don't think it is
inevitable at all that it starts to
disintegrate I think on the contrary the
scale of the problems facing countries
is coming to be perceived as Kissinger
said as unprecedented interdependence
and I think people also look at what's
happening in places like Ukraine and
they see the chaos that that sort of
Russian intervention ISM can lead to and
I think that is driving people to want
to cooperate more but they want to
cooperate on a more modern basis than we
have had hitherto so I think the
challenge for diplomats like me is to
find what is that modern basis that
renews the purpose of the United Nations
but has space in it
for all these new powers to come in and
work more closely together where does
the UK fit into this where does brexit
fit into this you know at one level you
might think it sounds a little bit
strange to be talking about a
stern robust defense of the multilateral
system and then for the United Kingdom
to be leaving an organization an
institution even I would argue it's not
that strange I don't think the threat to
multilateralism comes from countries or
individuals for that matter exercising
their inherent and legal right to
withdraw from institutions and treaties
we may disagree with president Trump's
decision to withdraw from the Paris
climate change agreement but that is a
very different thing from the illegal
annexation of Crimea those two things
are not comparable and we need to be
very clear what we're dealing with
when we talk about them the United
Kingdom is following its democratic vote
to leave the European Union but we have
stressed and all our politicians stress
that we are not leaving Europe we will
still share your values we still base
our society around the Universal
Declaration on human rights we will
still be in NATO we will come to the
defence of NATO members in the way that
we are obliged to and we will
unconditionally support Europe's
security and safety and ministers have
made that very clear the exact terms of
the UK's withdraw from brexit and the
new relationship we will have with the
European Union as you will know is under
discussion we expect it to be resolved
in the coming weeks we want it on our
site to be based around a genuine
partnership but a partnership that
really enables free trade and enables
Britain to maximize the prospects of
free trade not just for ourselves but
for all our partners free trade is a
very difficult concept I think for
public's to grasp
ever since Lloyd George managed to refer
to a bread tax in order to bring
to people quite what protectionism was
really doing to their food supply it has
been counterintuitive I think for
domestic opinion to really rally to the
notion of free trade but it is the
concept that has on the whole kept the
world moving forward economically so you
will find us still being a champion of
free trade and of things that go with
that of competitiveness and productivity
improvements and I think it's very
important to set that out economically
because there aren't too many champions
of open trading at the moment and I
think it's very important that we don't
lose the gains that that has brought
over the years we are still working out
with the European Union our exact
trading relationship with them you will
have heard in the press that the Prime
Minister has put forward a checkers
model which is based around a certain
degree of alignment there are also other
models out there but for the moment the
United Kingdom is working on the basis
of the Prime Minister's proposals and we
are hopeful that we will be able to
reach agreement with our European Union
partners but we will always continue to
work very closely with them in
multilateral fora whether that's in the
UN whether it's ad hoc in places like
the OSCE whether it's coming together in
the Human Rights Council we have too
much in common
to be easily divided though we are sure
that there will be some malign forces
out there that will try and exploit any
differences but we also feel very
strongly it is unprecedented and though
not impossible obviously for a country
to leave the European Union in our view
that means there can be unprecedented
new arrangements for the relationship
that we have with the European Union
having left we will not just be any old
third country we will be a very special
who for 40 years shared in many of the
successes of the European Union and
indeed led some of them so we hope to be
able to put all that together finalize
the withdrawal treaty and work out our
new relationship with some of our
closest friends I think if you turn
around and look towards the United
States from Europe I think a Britain
that has more independence of action
will actually be an even better friend
to the United States of America we will
be able to join the United States in
certain ventures eg on sanctions but we
will also have at our core
I think the role that Churchill
originally envisioned for the United
Kingdom he saw strong United States of
Europe and a strong United States of
America with a very strong United
Kingdom in the middle so a three-legged
stool and I think we need to do our
utmost to make that work because as I
was saying earlier the forces of malign
activity in the world are really
contesting the model that we have sought
to build since 1945 and I think the most
useful thing we can do for future
generations is to make that
three-pronged approach as open and
responsive to world affairs as possible
while being open to collaboration with
all those countries who believe in
representative government who believe in
freedom of assembly who believe in
freedom of expression so all those
really core principles on which the
world has functions so well and the
United Nations has functioned so well
since 1945 thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much ambassador piers and
you've given us a great deal to talk
about the geopolitical context and the
issues that exist in the world the
challenges in the UN in a UN of 193
countries quite different from the UN of
1945 and the relationship the evolving
relationship of the UK with with Europe
and of course with the US and with China
and Russia so real tour de force and
you've given us a lot to talk about and
I think I'd like to open it up to some
questions and I see Paul Kennedy sitting
here who may be interested in talking
about any one of those issues ambassador
Paul Kennedy from a history department
thank you for coming to Yale we get too
few visits from the British delegation
or neither British Embassy in Washington
to this most Anglophile of the of the US
universities as you've seen by going to
the British Art Center and everything
else around here but thank you for
breaking that and coming to talk with us
ambassador I I was going to ask you a
question about UK and breakfast but my
my heart sinks and groans every morning
of the idiocy of a breakfast breakfast
tip so I won't can I come under
something more specific that you
mentioned which might have a possibility
of international improvement you
mentioned that going up to the to 2025
or 2020 you would be looking again at
the issue of reforming the UN Security
Council a group of us had yeah like a
demux was an International Commission
tried 23 years ago to produce a report
for Boutrous
butas gali called the United Nations in
its second half century which listed as
one of the key is used for improvement
reformed change the alteration in both
the processes of a security transfer and
a need for an enhanced membership of the
Security Council like many other
wonderful international reform proposals
it died in the dust because of a reality
of power politics and the veto system
the Security Council what chance do you
think there is for serious
constitutional change of the Security
Council in the next few years please
Kennedy it's a huge honor to be here and
also to see you sir and if it's helpful
for the UK mission to the UN to come
here more often I have some very lively
and brilliant people in my team who
would really relish the chance to come
and talk some of this through with with
you also if that's useful
professor Cameron Yuri we could perhaps
be in touch about that I think it's a
perfectly valid challenge and to a
certain extent some of us as status quo
powers in a way I'm an optimist and I
think you have to if you want anything
to change at the UN first of all believe
it can be done because if you start from
the premise that it's all too difficult
then what happens over time is that
people like India and they have already
said this move away from the
multilateral system they move outside
the UN and ultimately I don't think
that's that that's helpful so I think
there's there's a reason to keep trying
I think that without being Pangloss Ian
I think the context is different from
when you tried before it's even
different from when Kofi Annan tried to
reform the UN in 2005 and it's
differently precisely because of this
perceived challenge to the way the rules
of international affairs are set you
know and now we have always seen
invasions of other countries we have
always seen people withdraw from
treaties as I was saying earlier but
there is something about the scale of
what's happening there's something about
the economic might of China and her
almost expeditionary approach there's
something about the risks of a potential
us disengagement that I think you're
making people think more about this but
I also believe that those countries like
Brazil and India and South Africa who
argue for more intergovernmentalism as
opposed to Supra nationalism but
intergovernmentalism within the UN
Framework I have to say I think they
have a point now it is incredibly
difficult to reform the Security Council
for all the reasons you were saying it
involves changing the Charter and to
change the Charter or really under the
rules to require unanimity there may be
ways of getting around that but
principally of course it requires the
Security Council to be a turkey that
votes for Christmas and the veto is
there precisely so that major powers
don't have to face that choice and one
can lament that but I think it worth
recognizing that the veto is what has
kept the UN and the Security Council in
being for nearly 70 years and ensured it
didn't go the way of the League of
Nations so some of this somehow
expanding the Security Council will need
to include persuading Russia and China
that this is in their ultimate interests
and for that to happen it cannot be a
Western do-gooder enterprise the
emerging countries I referred to earlier
need to start telling the likes of
Russia and China that for example
economic investment will be linked to
their approach to reform of a body
like the Security Council yes over here
yes sir thank you for sharing your
thoughts with us
Rex it creates a major military deficit
in the European Union absent NATO
obviously and I heard you say that the
UK will always defend Europe my question
is do you see it do you see your
statement as leading to a treaty or do
you see the existing frameworks
sufficient to have helped to effectuate
your statement and well thank you
this is one of the issues that is being
discussed between the United Kingdom and
the European Union and it's one of
course in which Member States have a
critical interest as opposed to the
Commission perhaps negotiating on block
for the rest of the Union whether or not
there would need to be a separate treaty
I don't myself think they would need to
be we have article 5 in NATO we have a
number of clauses principles within the
European Union treaties that Britain is
already on record as saying we will
abide by I suspect there will need to be
specific agreements for specific
operations we await to see exactly how
data sharing and intelligence sharing
will come out there are implications
obviously for cooperation on
counterterrorism and cooperation on
things like sanctions in all of that
and we are awaiting the outcome of
negotiations to know exactly how the
implementation period the
that runs from 30th of March 2019 will
actually operate in impractical ways so
I think there may need to be specific
arrangements but in order to get the
principles right I wouldn't think that
we must start from the negotiating
position of a separate treaty yes thank
you ambassador you have mentioned that
you know this is going to set a
precedent obviously the withdrawal of
the UK from the European Union my first
part of my question is are you expecting
or are you striving to set an example as
to future exits can be based on the UK's
exit plan and the second one is the
European Union said many times
especially in response to the checkers
plan in Salzburg that there will be no
cherry-picking so how do you expect them
to come back and give you a counter
proposal based on the checkers plan
thank you thank you we are on record the
British government is is on record as
saying it wants the EU to succeed it is
not our intention to lead anybody else
out of the European Union we want the
European Union to thrive we want it to
be a force for good in the world for all
the reasons I was saying earlier about
the amount of malign activity that
together we need to contest president
macron has talked in terms of the
European developing in a way that has a
deeper inner core and a looser outer
ring and it is conceivable that over
time it would indeed develop in that way
but that's premature to talk of that
that now we we as I say we are not
encouraging anybody else to leave the
European Union
there are some countries and some
governments in the EU who think that
Britain must pay quite a harsh price for
leaving that we must be punished we
don't see it like that obviously but we
don't see it like that because as I say
this is unprecedented there is an
opportunity here to set the rules of
European affairs in a way that benefits
both sides and that is what we're going
to encourage the Commission and others
to to look at for obvious reasons but
one reason of course is trade and as I
was saying earlier free trade is going
to be a very helpful lubricant for
relations between Britain and the
European Union on the Prime Minister's
checkers proposals for the same reason
we don't see it as cherry-picking we see
it as a different concept the Prime
Minister is trying to find a credible
feasible workable way of meeting the
requirements of a productive and liberal
trading relationship regulatory
alignment and preserving the position of
Northern Ireland within the United
Kingdom and not giving any excuse to
those who would like to make the
Northern Ireland question harder and
more divisive and possibly even see a
return to violence so we will keep
talking to our European Union
counterparts about how best that can be
brought into interplay and there will be
some more discussions with the EU in
October and November so you'll forgive
me if I don't go into too much detail
because well we want a cooperative
relationship with the European Union it
would be stretching that too far to
actually tell them our negotiating
strategy
yes back here
Thank You ambassador so how will the US
representative to the United Nations
Nikki Haley's announcement to resign
affect the strength of UK US relations
and the United Nations and the
credibility of the partnership of the
two countries in the international
community well that's a very topical
question thank you but allow me to begin
by saying first of all that I admire
Ambassador Haley enormously both as an
individual person I value her friendship
she has been very kind to me since I
arrived
she's a very gracious person but I also
admire her professionally she has bags
of ambition she's driven things forward
in the UN such as to sanctions on North
Korea showing great negotiating skill
she saved money in the UN budget she's
pushed UN reform forwards she's made a
start on doing something about the
terrible situation in the conflict on
South Sudan so she has really been a
force for good and I think she is an
outstanding representative for the
America and the American people we
always work very closely with the
American government United States
government in the UN most of the time we
actually physically sit next to them
because a lot of the seating in the UN
is done alphabetically and we share many
of the same goals and objectives we
don't share all the same goals and
objectives we did not agree with the
move of the US Embassy to Jerusalem we
did not agree with the United States
putting out of the Iran nuclear deal so
it will not be seamless but what we do
share is the same overall goal about
maintaining international peace and
security and we and the French as you
will have seen acted with the Americans
in respect of the use of of chemical
weapons in Syria and all three of us are
on record as saying we will respond
appropriately if chemical weapons are
used again by the Syrian of
so there's a very close identity of Ames
there that I think transcends whoever
sits in the chair for either US or UK as
ambassador but ambassador Haley isn't
leaving yet we will be able to work with
her till the end of the year and we look
forward to that I look forward to that
yes over here we just had a new report
from the IPC which is extremely alarming
and given the current situation there I
mean there are sectors of American
society that that are participating in
meetings with the UN and trying to meet
goals what what what do you think of the
prospects in the in the near future for
work within the UN on our climate goals
I know there's another conference coming
up and how would you encourage American
people notwithstanding our president to
support these goals I think it was well
said at the point at which the u.s.
withdrew from Paris that actually
through voluntary action by individual
US states and other entities the United
States actually meets the majority of
its Paris commitments and I think that's
very important a because it shows
there's a very solid body of opinion in
this country that supports action
against climate change for all its
controversial in certain circumstances
but also that the work to make good on
those commitments and Paris continues
irrespective of that top level of
International Affairs so I think that's
definitely something to build on of
course we will continue to encourage
International Cooperation and encourage
the United States to engage with us on
more practical measures but the fact
that the voluntary side of things is
robust is a very good start I think
generally your question perhaps masks a
a view in America that fire struggles
with the value of the United Nations in
today's world I think that's a pity when
you look at the extent to which America
built the United Nations I don't know if
anyone has read the sledge injury book
about the founding of the UN but what
comes through that really clearly was
the effort that certain people in
Congress it was a bipartisan effort
people in the administration PA sees all
over America put into building the
institution that's the United Nations
and I think it would be good if the UN
itself can do more to explain to people
around the United States why it adds
value to us prosperity and security
I think climate change is a key part of
that yep
Thank You ambassador I was just
wondering like as the face of the UK in
the UN how you reconcile the UK's
professed mission to uphold human rights
and treasom a zone preoccupation with
protecting minorities with certain
domestic scandals like Windrush like on
the international stage thank you well
thank you thank you for the question
which is also very topical the British
government set out its position on
Windrush and it's made clear that it
shouldn't have happened and it will pay
compensation and people have lost their
jobs in government because of what
happened on Windrush so from that point
of view I don't see a contradiction
on the contrary although it's sad and
deeply regrettable that such actions
occurred the fact that there is redress
and the fact that there are apologies
are an important part of dealing with
human rights and trying to uphold the
principle of equality before the law the
British government has made some quite
liberal moves on human rights recently I
don't know if you followed
April's Commonwealth Heads of Government
Meeting but they're the government the
British government set out what it had
done on same-sex marriage but it also
noted that of the 53 countries in the
Commonwealth some 37 still have colonial
era legislation that restrict if not
outright ban LGBT activity and the
British government has said we will make
our legislative templates available and
our assistance available to any of those
Commonwealth governments who wish to
modernize their legislation so it is an
important issue for us we do keep moving
forwards I myself don't see a
contradiction at the UN
I'm proud to speak out in terms of what
the British government does but I think
all governments need to recognize that
there will always be occasions when
we're shown not to be perfect when we're
shown to have made mistakes I think what
matters as in so much of life is how you
own up to those mistakes and what you do
about putting them right and I think
actually on Windrush deeply regrettable
as it was the government has taken
action to do these things I think over
here
yeah thank you ambassador
[Applause]
one of the main people behind breaks it
was Boris Johnson your former boss it
was widely reported in British media
that he was a hugely incompetent foreign
secretary I wonder if you confirm or
deny those reports I'm not weaseling out
of the question but I didn't actually
hear it you want me to say if I deny the
reports that both Johnson was
incompetent well I'll make it even
easier for you I was his main policy
advisor because I was the Director
General for political affairs so I can
assure you he was not an incompetent
foreign secretary was and say well why
does the media report anything as
anything you know the media likes to
attach Homeric epithets to people there
is no doubt that Boris Johnson is an
interesting and at times divisive
character and has always been so and the
media liked to portray him in a certain
in a certain way and they didn't always
spend too much time looking at the
evidence so I would say in the time I am
my colleagues were working with Boris
Johnson you know we started a Yemen
political process we started in Libya
political process we supported the UN in
trying to get a Syrian one under way we
upheld the Iranian nuclear deal
he went to Iran he went to Russia the
actions of Russia were what brought the
crafting of a more productive
relationship to an end when the Russians
poisoned the scruples in Salisbury but I
think it was biased Johnson's contention
that we needed to put our shoulder to
the wheel on the really big foreign
policy issues of the day he was not
afraid to own up to mistakes on Syria on
Libya and elsewhere and he felt that
however difficult we needed to try and
make these things improve he was also a
huge advocate of girls education which
he saw as one of the chief drivers of
stability in countries particularly
economic stability but not just that so
along with the development International
Development Secretary he started a
campaign to support 12 years of quality
education for girls around the world but
as you also know he has a different
position now he's not in government so I
won't comment on his position at the
moment could i intervene while the
microphone is moving over there could i
intervene and ask a question about the
the geopolitical context the work that
we're witnessing in recent years ukraine
minsk still incomplete unfinished
business
russians still in control syria enormous
war crimes being committed yemen another
problem area the flow of refugees out of
the middle
to Europe which of course has created
enormous domestic political issues for
the Europeans in all of this it seems to
be the case the world we have now is a
world which is really dependent on what
the great powers are doing to each other
and not collectively and and it raises a
question about the the inability of the
UN to step into crises that are are of a
magnitude that we haven't witnessed
before and and so short of removing the
p5 veto which doesn't seem likely
anytime in the future even if the UN has
reworked some of the internal operations
how do we how do how do those interested
in the supranational governance reassert
their authority and legitimacy in the
face of well it's easy to figure name
one individual Vladimir Putin but but
others the Chinese and and and some
would say the Americans or the Iranians
or the other powers and you've seen this
in your own career firsthand in the case
you were ambassador in Afghanistan which
is a long-standing and continuing battle
so what are the prospects for do you see
without a reorganization of the UN
institutions for a reassertion of
supranational governance and and
authority for the rules of the
traditional liberal international
world I think the first thing I'd say
Professor Kerin is I don't see the two
things as contradictory I think you can
have both great power collaboration and
supernatural supranational frameworks
for rules and values in fact I think
some of these really difficult issues
like Syria but before them
Miranda's Reverend each going back even
further career actually can't be done or
can't be done alone by a body like the
UN precisely because they involve so
many national interests and so many
critical national interests of really
powerful nations but what you can have
and have had is cooperation between
those nations notably the US and Soviet
Union and Russia but not only to use the
UN for certain tasks but to agree a way
forward between themselves and this has
happened intermittently on Syria but
never at a critical mass enough to make
a lasting difference on the ground it
could still happen again the key as you
say is President Putin and I think one
of the keys to President Putin is
actually all these other countries like
Saudi Arabia the Emirates even China
which has a different slant on these
sorts of issues saying to him that it is
actually important not necessarily just
for the sake of the UN but for regional
stability and security and things like
the security of shipping in the goal
that Russia starts to cooperate and you
see a little bit of this on the
agreement she reached with Turkey on it
Lib you see other countries in fact
coming to the fore that aren't great
powers because their interests are
directly engaged and who knows exactly
how that will
that play out I think there's a big
question on it Lib as to whether this is
a reprieve or a stay of execution
obviously we hope it's the former but a
lot of people fear it may be that the
latter but certainly for the moment that
is holding and the United States is is
backing it so I don't think it's um it's
inevitable that this sort of thing can't
happen the Balkans there are a series of
agreements in the Balkans beginning with
Dayton which which should hold procore
castrated where the Russians did come in
and cooperate after 9/11 as I mentioned
earlier the Iranians and even the
Syrians did come and cooperate on CTE a
lot depends on the individual leaders
and a lot depends on how the the
national interests of each country are
framed so we need to obviously do better
at bringing the commonalities to the
fore but where we can't do that then the
one thing the west can do is stand back
until the Russians are ready to accept
Western help which will mean accepting a
proper political process on Syria and
we've been very clear that we won't put
reconstruction money into Syria till we
see that process we will however put
humanitarian in and I think that also
underscores another bit of the
international system which we haven't
talked about which is the extent to
which the West pays for it
and now you know emerging powers to
Saudis credit Emirates the Emirates
credit Kuwait credit that they are
putting huge amounts of donor funding
into Syria the countries which aren't a
Russia and China and that sad to say is
a form of leverage yes over here right
right here and
t-shirt yeah yeah right there ambassador
thank you very much for your thoughts I
would like to come back to brexit for
one second so usually when you want to
leave an institution you may you need
some reason right I mean of course in
your case it's the people's will you had
a referendum but you said for example
you would like the EU to succeed so I
would guess you agree with the values of
the EU and things like that so what is
the main problem or what is the main
advantage of brexit so from the UK
perspective so what problem you can
solve by leaving the U and what is kind
of the opportunity for making such a
step we didn't the British people the
British government British opposition in
Parliament didn't sit down and do a
cost-benefit analysis of whether to stay
in or leave the European Union the
question came up as a result of a
commitment made by the previous Prime
Minister and then you had a campaign and
as you say you had a referendum and a
democratic decision and that was all
based on rules set by Parliament so we
are we are where we are and the Prime
Minister has been really clear that we
will make a success of brexit for very
many people in the UK it goes back to
that Churchill quote I mentioned earlier
you have the United States of America
you have a United States of Europe and
you have a United Kingdom in the middle
for all sorts of historical reasons
Britain has a very different tradition
from very many in fact most of the
European Union members and we can talk
about that but it's it's you know
self-evident in in many ways and Britain
has never really seen the European
institutions as necessary to protect her
against the ravages of her own
government as has happened in
recent centuries in some of Europe's
other members so we start from a
fundamentally different place and for
anyone who hasn't read it I commend a
book by Dominick Sam Brooke about the
1970s in Britain which describes the
sorts of questions put to the general
public as Britain was going into the
European Union 40 years ago and you can
map some of those onto the responses you
heard around brexit which i think is
fundamentally something about national
character and national desiderata that
said we have an awful lot in common
with the European Union member states
and we want this to succeed and we want
it to be a success for them as well
nothing is inevitable this is a very
unusual unprecedented move it deserves
an unprecedented level of partnership
it's right right over here a fellow with
the glasses yep hi thank you very much
for your talk and so you've said that
the British government is on record
saying that it wants the European Union
to succeed brexit hasn't happened yet
and within the context of the ongoing
negotiations
I think this stance is very pragmatic
but do you think that if brexit proves
to be difficult domestically for the UK
but which by all forecasts it suggested
it will in the short term at least the
same goodwill that exists at the moment
will fade as a British citizen I can't
help but think that the brexit process
is simply initiating greater anti-eu
sentiment within domestic politics even
if we get checkers checkers is
unacceptable to many politicians
including Boris Johnson because it isn't
the dream Brecht set that they had
envisioned this is simply providing fuel
for a populist movement that we need to
be more independent from Europe blaming
Europe for being harsh on the UK during
brexit negotiations and thus inflaming
further anti-eu sentiment rather than
further cooperation I think
the premise of that I'm not going to
comment on individual politicians in the
United Kingdom Simon civil servants so
it's my job to be politically objective
and neutral and impartial the British
civil service is not like the American
civil service we do not have political
appointments so you will forgive me if I
have to be completely neutral and
impartial on this question but it is my
job to support the government and the
government has set out very clearly that
we will make a success of brexit however
we come to define that and I think there
is still enormous amounts of goodwill in
Britain for the European Union member
states and our relations with them our
history have been engaged in Europe goes
back centuries and will endure and I
think the converse is also true there is
a tremendous amount of goodwill in the
European Union for Britain and what
Britain represents particularly on the
world stage I can see someone shaking
their heads but that's how that's how it
looks to me
when you see
well that's not the policy of the
British government which which I've set
out I think there is a lot of
recognition that there's a lot of shared
history and common values with Europe
and there's a lot of recognition that a
liberal trading relationship with Europe
ISM with the EU is in both science
interests and there is a lot of
recognition that there are some very
serious threats coming to European have
already come to European security from
the actions of Russia and that we must
stand together on that
so actually what I see are things that
are transcending some of the the
geography just in the issues we have to
deal with now and I think that is going
to continue and I think we will be able
to find a productive way of working with
the European Union even as we are
outside it could I intervene and ask a
question from the point of view of
Europe notwithstanding my name from the
point of view of Europe is brexit a good
thing for the Europeans in terms of
security policy foreign policy one of
the great achievements of of the treaty
on European Union the Maastricht Treaty
was the creation of a common foreign and
security policy and and the csdp that
we've had that has come from that and
Europe is obviously stronger as a United
States of Europe and a Churchillian
sense stronger with the UK in then and
out in terms of security yes we have
NATO
but I would think from the point of view
of the EU it will feel that it is much
less capable of asserting itself
globally regionally geopolitically in
terms of security without the UK in the
meetings making the policies so from a
European and this is something that
really doesn't seem to get TUC talked
about much in the media there's so much
focus about checkers and trade and so
forth but but it does seem to me the the
entire area of security cooperation
intelligence sharing all of this is a
very important setback for the Europeans
if I were a European leader I'd be
probably as much concerned about that as
anything else
so is that right or SHhhh or can the
Europeans say oh well we'll always have
the UK with us because we're all in NATO
well as you know not only European Union
countries are in NATO so that's a nice
little a about the ones that some of
them no it's still benefiting from the
nuclear umbrella that they were robots
but that's a separate set of questions
and I think you're right there hasn't
been a huge amount of focus publicly on
the security side and that is definitely
something where Britain has enhanced
Europe's approach and the --use
capabilities so that's a very important
asset it's a very important relationship
and it's going to be even more important
as a matter of practicality if one looks
at the sorts of things that the Russians
and the GI you have been doing recently
and the latest of course was publication
of what the Dutch had found in relation
to GRU officers trying to attack the
International chemical weapons
institution in The Hague and I think
these things are very much at the back
of leaders Minds
and they are one of the things that keep
the negotiations moving forward but the
Prime Minister has been clear we're not
going to bargain with with Europe's
security but yes it is an important part
of what will be the future relationship
between us yes right here hi Thank You
ambassador
and the country which other than the UK
will probably be affected most by
bracketed Ireland and in the NEET
Churchillian notion of the u.s. the
United States of Europe and Britain it's
not clear where our own lies there and
there's a lot of anxiety in Ireland at
the moment and partly just as a result
of the UK sovereign decision to leave
but partly also because of the and well
indifference and hostility to the Good
Friday Agreement among at least British
politicians and arguably somewhat to the
British government
so I spoke my questions whether Good
Friday Agreement in view of the British
government is sacrosanct or in the same
way that you respect the right of
President Trump to bring the USA of the
Paris Accord whether we should respect
the right of Britain to pull out the
Good Friday Agreement well I have to say
I'm a bit horrified by that question the
government and Teresa may have made it
very clear that Northern Ireland is an
integral part of the United Kingdom but
that it is absolutely vital to preserve
the peace process and to preserve the
gains that have been achieved on both
sides as a result of the Good Friday
Agreement and we recognise that the
current situation has a lot of
difficulties in it for Island we want to
work through those with our Irish
counterparts and the Irish Prime
Minister and his government it does go
back to the nature of the checkers trade
deal a lot of the other issues are
capable of being resolved without
bringing the border question into play
but the Prime Minister has been very
clear that she has the welfare
of Northern Ireland as a whole right at
the centre of what she's trying to
achieve and we we recognize that Britain
and Island are very closely linked in
the European Union for people who don't
know we have some special arrangements
that apply just to Ireland and the
United Kingdom and we need to work very
closely together to find a way of not
losing all those gains but there's no
doubt in the government's mind that the
political process the peace process in
Northern Ireland
is extremely precious and that we want
to keep it and we want to preserve those
gains for the citizens on both sides of
that border thank you very much I'm
afraid that we have to bring this to a
close we could go on for quite a long
time but there are classes that are
going to be meeting in a very short
amount of time a few minutes so I want
to thank the ambassador for being here
and please join me and in thank you
[Music]